lady would sit down and say I haven't
worked out in 7 years and I I know I
need to be going to the gym and I would
say that's amazing they would just be
shocked what do you mean I'm like you're
so consistent so you already have the
tra of consistency I was like we just
have to flip it and they were like never
thought about it like that for me I just
wanted this person to believe they could
do it and so I think to the same degree
it's like well if every day you didn't
make the piece of content that you
wanted to but up until that point you've
always like been able to like make a cup
of coffee sit down at the computer
rather than playing video games it's
counting the wins sometimes of of losses
that didn't happen